hi my name is raphael hostetler i am the
founder
and future robot number one of devantro
the robot company
we are building robots that copy or
imitate the human body
we are doing something that's called
telepresence and telepresence has been
sporting
your presence senses and action from one
point in space
to another it's a bit like teleportation
but you're sort of jumping into a robot
so the audience will see a very well
hopeful interesting and lively
discussion on what it takes to
bridge people together and bring them
closer to each other in
especially the current very difficult
times
and we are not just talking about it but
we are showing it live
um so laura koicheva is in
munich during this event and instead of
being present
at the event through video call or other
means nowadays that sort of
limit her capacity of physical
interaction she will be embodying
a humanoid robot robo is a very special
type of robot and what makes it special
is that
it imitates the human musculoskeletal
system so the robot has muscles and
tendons like we humans do
and that's in contrast to most other
robots out there who usually
have motions in their joints and now you
might ask why would you want to do this
and this is we're doing this because it
builds or creates robots that are closer
to the human body
they behave more like the human body so
the emotions are more fluent
uh they the passive dynamics so if you
for example touch a robot or if you
shake its hand although it's off it's
much more like it would be for a human
so the grand challenge about building a
human robot like grow boy and the
telepresence system is basically
everything
uh because we basically have to bring
together and solve a lot of very small
problems in
many many technologies so we're
integrating recent results from
virtual reality augmented reality
artificial intelligence
uh of course robotics but also like
how you interact um with the robot and
then i even work with an anthropologist
to understand how we need to build these
systems to
truly give people like the feeling of
connectedness